[Musique]
londres 1982 monsieur alim tonnes est
plutôt pro europe
bon moi je suis toujours pour le marché
commun et madame aline tonnes aimé plus
de réserves
nous espérons beaucoup que la vie
s'améliorerait avec le marché commun
en fait c'est le contraire qui se
produit mais ali tonnes sont à l'image
de l'opinion britannique très divisé sur
le sujet européen et ce depuis que le
royaume uni a intégré la communauté en
1973 voilà ce qu'en disait alors un
groupe de jeunes il serait très
imprudent
la chose est entrée dans le marché
commun et la vie des plus anciens je
n'aime pas les indépendances ont pensé
soi même créer soi-même sa façon de
vivre en 1975 deux ans après l'adhésion
les travaillistes succède au
conservateur au pouvoir à peine installé
il organisera un référendum 67% de la
population vote en faveur du maintien
dans la communauté européenne 32% contre
la ville de bradford a été le théâtre
d'affrontements
certes modérée entre partisans du oui et
du non en 1989 les élections européennes
n'intéressent pas la population le taux
de participation est de 38%
il ya un il ici et à la manche
et 1801 côté de l'europe en 1991 ils
sont les seuls à refuser l'euro et la
suppression des frontières là c'est un
certain chauvinisme qui s'expriment perd
donc un peu notre identité nous avons
déjà changé nos pousser nos ongles pour
des g et des mg et en 2012 ce n'est pas
un vote mais en sondages quatre ans
avant le break site 56 % de l'opinion se
dit en faveur de la sortie de l'union
roc en fait ne fonctionne pas nous
sommes les seuls à bien m'en sortir
soumis au référendum en 2016 le vrai
exit et voté à 51,9 % et si le vote
avait eu lieu à nouveau en janvier 2019
le brésil ne seraient pas approuvés 56 %
des britanniques auraient choisi de
rester dans l'union
[Musique]